c-span 2's book tv
and follow us on twitter for the latest
schedule updates
american university anthropology
professor david vine talks about diego
garcia a u.s military base on an island
in the indian ocean the base is a launch
pad for aircraft used in the wars in
afghanistan and iraq
modern times bookstore in san francisco
hosts this event it's an hour
[Applause]
thank you all so much for coming um it's
really exciting to be here in the bay
area to begin with and to be surrounded
by so many fabulous friends
um i feel very honored um and to meet
some new friends and make some new
friends and the
the bay area and the mission in
particular i think feels like exactly
the right place to be releasing the book
um as it is being officially released
today um a neighborhood in an area so
committed to issues of social justice so
uh it feels right and a home to me
wherever i happen to lay my head
so
i also want to thank modern times
because they're amazing and a great
bookstore a great independent bookstore
and so generous and nice to host me so
thanks to everyone at modern times
um
i thought it was important just to
situate diego garcia to start so i
brought along a nice map
um
diego garcia smack dab in the middle of
the indian ocean halfway between africa
and australia a thousand miles from the
nearest man last land mass
a few people know about diego garcia and
that's part of the impetus behind the
book to tell a story that that so few
people know
um
luckily i suppose for me in a
slightly perverse way the indian ocean
is suddenly in the in the news of late
um we hear about pirates in the indian
ocean um in many ways this is a story
about piracy in the indian ocean piracy
of a different kind um and the creation
of what is another guantanamo another
base like the base at guantanamo bay
cuba
it's the story of the creation of a
major u.s military base and the
expulsion of the indigenous people of
diego garcia and the surrounding chagos
archipelago
what i'm going to do is is talk a bit
about about the book and my research um
and take some questions in the middle
after i um go over some of the history
and then talk a little bit more and read
some from the book and then hopefully
take some more questions and have you
know a discussion and
love to hear your thoughts
so some know diego garcia as a major u.s
military base one of the most important
strategically in the world for us
military officials
the base has been a major launch pad for
the wars in iraq and afghanistan
contrary to the repeated denials of the
bush administration and british
officials the base
has been identified as one of the more
than two dozen cia black sites around
the world where
terrorist suspects are held and detained
and possibly tortured
finally last year u.s and british
officials acknowledged that contrary to
their former denials
that people have in fact been held there
far fewer know that to create the base
the u.s government in conjunction with
the british government it is british
territory
forcibly exiled the entire indigenous
people of diego garcia and the chagos
archipelago people known as the
chagosians
1200 miles away to the western indian
ocean islands of mauritius and the
seychelles
the expulsion took place between 1968
and 1973 in a process that i'll describe
in just a second
i should just
back up um and explain a bit about how i
um came to be involved in the case uh in
the story
and that was through lawsuits that the
jagosians
were bringing and have been bringing
against the u.s and british governments
to gain the right of return to their
homelands and proper compensation
for um their suffering and exile
and part of what i'll describe is the
ways in which jagossian's lives have
been deeply impoverished in exile um
like other
groups who have been forcibly displaced
they have
lived lives on the whole mired in deep
deep poverty
some know mauritius in the seychelles as
exotic tourist destinations um the
chigosians lives are far removed from
the tourist beaches and luxury hotels of
mauritius and the seychelles they're
generally living as the poorest of the
poor the lowest of the low
as marginalized outsiders in exile
but in about in the summer of 2001
almost eight years ago i got a phone
call one one afternoon um from one of
the lawyers representing the chegosians
and they needed an expert witness to
uh conduct research to document the ways
in which the chagosians expulsion has
affected their let their lives
and that led to research initially for
the lawsuit but very quickly i realized
there was a bigger story i wanted to
tell
i wanted to understand why the us
government and its officials exiled this
entire group of people
who at the time numbered 1500 to 2 000
and i wanted to understand why
we have a military base in the middle of
the indian ocean in the first place why
do we in the minds of military officials
need a military base in the middle of
the indian ocean
um and that led to the book which is in
effect a two-pronged story
uh one part telling the story of the
chagosians and their their lives both
before and after the expulsion the other
part telling the story of the u.s
government officials who orchestrated
the expulsion
and the larger story of of the empire
that the united states has become
and the ways in which diego garcia can
help us understand something about that
empire
um as i'll discuss at the very end
the book also focuses on the chugosian's
struggle to return to their homeland
um and and
through lawsuits and other means
which i'll i'll come to at the end
let me start by by talking a little
about the life of one shigosian i i
focus on on one family of chagosians as
a way to to explore the experience of
the chagosians as a group
her name is is rita bancu
i'll pass around the book in a little
while but this is a picture of rita
um sitting here in her sunday best at a
chigosian festival
you were born chagost replied rita banku
before i could finish my question
in what year
1928 the 30th of june
rita grew up in one of chagos's island
groups perospanos about a hundred miles
away from diego garcia
la monet la memmon rest she added in the
song like up and down cadence of
chagostian's creole
la monet la memmon rest day
the island where i was born is the
island where i stayed
and your parents i asked what island
were your parents born on
my parents were born there too rita
explained
my grandmother the mother of my father
was born on six islands ceciles
my grandmother my father was also born
in six islands my grandfather was born
there too
my grandmother on my mother's side was
born in perospanos
rita does not know where her other
ancestors were born one of the injuries
still carried by people with enslaved
forebearers however however she
remembers her grandmother olivet pauline
saying that rita's
great-great-grandmother
had been enslaved and had the name
masambo or mazambo
rita thinks she was a mao gas a person
from madagascar
in fact the chagosians are the
descendants of enslaved africans and
indentured indians who
began being brought to chagos to diego
garcia and the other islands of the
archipelago beginning around the time of
the american revolution in the late 18th
century
franco mauritians brought the jagosians
or their ancestors
to chagos to work on and build coconut
plantations on the islands the islands
had
previously been uninhabited as far as
anyone knows
and over time over the next almost 200
years the jugosians this diverse group
of people
came to form a distinct and unique
people with its own french and
bantu-based creole language
and distinct cultural and other
traditions
by the 1960s mauritian
governor
robert scott described diego garcia as
having the look of a french coastal
village miraculously transferred whole
to this shore
and it's important to point out that
the islands and the lives they lived
were far from luxurious these were most
definitely plantation societies
but over the 200 years in which they
lived on the islands they had struck
what was for a plantation society a
relatively good work bargain there was
universal employment and in exchange for
the labor people had regular salaries
and in cash and food
as well as a range of social benefits
free education
health care they have their own land
their own houses
and a range of other social benefits
on islands that it should be pointed out
are described by many as idyllic these
are gorgeous tropical islands in the
middle of the indian ocean
um
rita put it this way
life there paid very little
a very little rita said but it was the
sweet life
that life began coming to an end however
in the late 1950s when a man named
stuart barber who was a civilian in the
u.s navy was working in the pentagon
living outside of washington dc in the
virginia suburbs not far from where i
live actually
when stuart barber identified diego
garcia as an ideal location
for a u.s naval base
barber who is also who was one of the
u.s officials who i who i um
whose life i explore in the book
created what he called the strategic
island concept in the late 1950s
u.s military officials were growing
increasingly concerned
that the united states would begin
losing its overseas military bases in
the wake of decolonization that as
nations formerly colonized nations
gained their independence they would
begin kicking out the us from our bases
overseas um and barbara and others began
looking for ways to replace these bases
and barbara seized upon this idea called
that he called the strategic island
concept under which the u.s would
identify and acquire one way or another
strategically located small
lightly populated islands on which they
could later build bases
and quickly diego garcia emerged as a
prime candidate
i'll read a little from
the way barbara described diego garcia
after finding all to all the other
islands he looked at he looked the
search was literally global um for small
islands around the world
after finding all the other sites to be
inferior stu found quote that beautiful
atoll of diego garcia right in the
middle of the ocean
saw that the small v-shaped island was
blessed with a central location within
striking distance of potential conflict
zones
one of the world's great natural harbors
in its protected lagoon
and enough land to build a large
airstrip
but the navy still needed to ensure it
would get a base absent any messy
political complications
any targeted island would have to be
quote free of impingement on any
significant indigenous population or
economic interest
stu was pleased to note that diego
garcia's population was quote measured
only in the hundreds in fact the
population was about a thousand at the
time and the other islands of chagos had
about 500 to a thousand as well so the
total population was about two thousand
um but the cia put it even more bluntly
when it estimated the size of the
population as n e g l
negligible
which
i think speaks volumes for the way that
u.s officials thought about the
chagosians
quickly other members of the national
security bureaucracy and the initially
in the kennedy administration later in
the johnson administration seized upon
barber's strategic island concept and
diego garcia in particular
kennedy approved plans to create a base
in 1963
and
initiated secret negotiations with the
british government
beginning in 1960 and continuing on for
the next several years in 1964 u.s
officials inserted
a
another
stipulation as part of their
negotiations that the united states
would gain access to diego garcia that
it would gain quote exclusive control of
diego garcia without local inhabitants
and interestingly they put the without
local inhabitants in a parenthetical
phrase
so it was in essence uh the document
shows uh an expulsion order embedded
bureaucratically in a parenthetical
phrase
um in 1966
the two governments finalized their deal
with what was called an exchange of
notes which is effectively a treaty
between two governments but unlike a
treaty this exchange of notes doesn't
have to come before congress or
parliament so this was a way in which
the two governments kept the entire deal
secret um and hidden from
from congress and and parliament and
from the world and from the beginning um
the all the negotiations were carried
out in secret there were efforts to
make sure only certain details came out
in the few
newspaper articles that that appeared in
the mid 60s
part of this exchange of notes um
included
an additional they were they were
actually published officially to very
little attention but there were there
were secret notes that were signed
between the two governments and they
made
provision for 14 million dollars in
secret payments that the united states
would
make to great britain in exchange for
the islands again in a way that
circumvented congressional oversight and
the need to ask congress for an
appropriation
and what was described as those
administrative measures necessary for
resettling the inhabitants of the chagos
archipelago
those administrative measures meant that
beginning in 1968
when shigosians were in mauritius for
regular
medical care or regular
vacations when they went to return home
they were simply told your islands have
been closed you can't ever go there
again so they were marooned in mauritius
separated from many cases from their
their families from their homes from
their lands their communities their
graves of their ancestors
as the 1960s came to a close british
officials began restricting supplies to
the islands and conditions started
to deteriorate
causing more chigosians to leave in the
hopes of returning to their islands
once conditions improved
you
might ask you know did anyone object
the only objections were actually raised
about another base that was part of
stuart barbour's strategic island
concept plan
that was a base on an island called
daldabra where
in the late 1960s
scientists began protesting that the
creation of a base there would endanger
a group of rare tortoises um and
red-footed boobies and another
uh some other um rare indian ocean
animals
essentially no one stood up to protest
on behalf of the chagosians
i should also say in line with their
the other efforts that u.s and british
officials took to
uh keep the entire creation of the base
and the expulsion secret um british
officials uh crafted in in tandem with
u.s officials what they called
what was a
public relations plan to in the words of
british officials maintain the fiction
that the chagosians were simply
transient laborers migrant workers um if
that is if anyone bothered to ask about
them which only happened on a couple
occasions
so instead of acknowledging that they
were deeply connected to these islands
and having lived there for five
generations or more
that they would simply represent to the
world that they were migrant laborers
who actually belonged in mauritius and
could be sent along
and in fact that's what then happened
in 1971 the u.s navy began construction
on the base on diego garcia
and
u.s navy officials issued orders to the
british to complete the removals
um
i should say one one rare instance in
which some
u.s navy officials stood up and said
wait a second um they were actually u.s
navy personnel on the island and some of
them began meeting the chicago scenes
who were still there and some of them
cabled back to the pentagon
wait a second these people have been
living here they're not they don't look
like transient laborers
the response from the highest-ranking
official in the u.s navy admiral elmo
zumwalt
was a three-word memo
absolutely must go
and so
they did
british officials with u.s navy
personnel looking on rounded up the
chagosians and put them on overcrowded
cargo ships
and deported them 1200 miles away to
mauritius and the seychelles in the
western indian ocean
and in the process
of the
deportations they actually rounded up
the chagosians pet dogs and put them in
sealed sheds where they gassed and
burned them in front of the chigosians
who were awaiting deportation
one of the chigosians lawyers has
pointed out that this sent a strong
message to the jugosians about what
might happen if they protested the
removals
and so between 1971 and 1973 the all the
remaining chagosians were deported to
mauritius and the seychelles where there
was no resettlement plan in place and
where they quickly found found
themselves in what the washington post
called
abject poverty
and my research has shown that that
despite some very small amounts of
compensation that they finally received
five and ten years after the last
expulsions the chigosians have remained
deeply impoverished in exile
i think i'll stop right there just to
ask if you have any questions about the
history um because it's new and um and
then i'll read a little bit more from
the book
to what extent did any of the chagosians
themselves like mobilize against what
was being done to them either early or
late in that process
yeah um
a really good question and from the
beginning from 1968 when the first
jugosians were marooned and barred from
returning
they initially went to the mauritian
government and said
because they were in mauritius and said
we want to go home
so it was
and you see cables and and and um the
mauritian government
approaching british officials on their
behalf um but all these requests were
turned down
um the same happened in 1971 when
shigozi and san diego garcia were told
you have to leave
people said
this is our country we don't want to
leave our country um
and and in a second i'll
talk more about
the organizing and struggle that they've
waged in exile
it sounds like there was a
i couldn't quite follow but
at one point it's a british colony
before that was it a french colony or
how did that yeah good a good question
in a part of the history i
skimmed over um initially it was um a
french colony that was part of the
french colony of mauritius
um in the napoleonic wars at the turn of
the 19th century
it became a british possession
and remained part of the british then
british colony of mauritius until
1964 and 65 when as part of the creation
of a base on diego garcia
british officials at the urging of the
us government created
what became britain's last colony last
created colony called the british indian
ocean territory
which was explicitly a colony created to
create military bases um
uh in which there would be no population
um
i remember i heard the story before and
part of the deal from what i'd heard
when uh
the uh british and the americans were
figuring out how to get diego garcia
part of it was they were the british got
sort of a cut-rate deal on trident
nuclear missiles for their submarines is
that a confirmed thing yeah that's
absolutely right that was um the payment
of 14 million dollars was
again
done in a way that to avoid having to go
before congress and ask for a 14 million
appropriation
the u.s simply wiped out a 14 million
dollar debt that the brits owed
to the u.s government for these missile
systems
did
was the government of mauritius warned
or consulted about these people that
were just going to appear there
uh
consulted um they were warned in a
certain sense they were told in in the
midst of their independence negotiations
with the british government um that
uh the jugosians would be coming
and they were
essentially given a choice
that
they could either accept three million
pounds from the british government out
of the 14 million dollars that the u.s
paid
um
and have the chagus archipelago chopped
off of mauritian territory to create the
british indian ocean territory or they
could
gain and they would gain independence or
there'd be no independence um so they
were given a choice
give up chagos take the for the three
million pounds um or
no independence
um
and then they were subsequently paid 650
000 pounds to
resettle on the chagosians although
british and u.s officials understood all
along that first of all that was far too
little to properly resettle an entire
population and second of all that giving
this
letting
this newly independent nation take the
responsibility for resettling an entire
population was
deeply irresponsible given that
the needs and given the the difficulties
that mauritius was having in its
transition to independence
and when the people arrived to the new
island what kind of facilities were
provided to them any shelter anything to
support their new life isn't there
anything that's an important question as
essentially there was no resettlement
assistance provided initially
chigosians were literally left on the
docks um in when they were deported
and had to find their way to
um to find homes to find they they were
arrived unemployed home literally
homeless um and just had to find anyone
who would let them in take them in some
had family members living in mauritius
and they doubled up or
as i mentioned in in 1978 five years
after the last deportations
they received some small compensation
and again in 1982 but it totaled for
those who received it and not all
received it totaled about six thousand
dollars um and really improved their
conditions
marginally um
so they've remained sort of the lowest
of the low in in exile right away there
there was nothing nothing there was one
group of of people who came in one of
the last boatloads from diego garcia who
because they and to answer the other
question um they
knew the fate of some of their the
previous people who had been deported
when they arrived in mauritius they
stayed on the boat and said we're not
getting off the boat unless you take us
back to jaguar garcia or you provide us
some you know way to support ourselves
here
and eventually they they receive some
decrepit abandoned housing near the
mauritian docks
but that was it
no
jobs no nothing
just one more i realize this isn't
really
the key issue but just so i can picture
it better can you say a little bit about
the physical dimensions of diego garcia
yes and this is another um i i meant to
say that thank you um
usually i present with with photos which
which help diego garcia is um
uh it's actually not all that peculiar
for a coral atoll um but for those
unfamiliar um
it sort of looks like a um a heart
almost or a v um sort of like this uh
the inside is a big a giant lagoon and
that's what's one of the reasons the us
navy
liked it um
you can host an entire aircraft carrier
task force in this lagoon um and then it
had enough room for it's about 13 months
it's about the size of manhattan 13
miles long
and about five or six miles at its
broadest um
so it also had enough room for a runway
and it has a huge runway which is now
home to b52 b2 b1 bombers a whole array
of other air force
planes
maybe i should keep going and then
come back to other questions
okay i want to now come back to the
story of rita bancu
and her experience in exile
um she was one of the she and her family
were were some of the ones who arrived
in mauritius in 1968 and were barred
from returning they were seeking medical
care for rita's youngest daughter
here's how rita
described
that day
when she was told she couldn't return
rita felt like she'd been sliced open
and all the blood spilled from her body
what happened to you what happened to
you her children cried as they came
running to her side
what happened her husband inquired
did someone attack you they asked
i heard everything they said rita
recounted but my voice couldn't open my
mouth to say what had happened
for an hour she said nothing her heart
swollen with emotion
finally she blurted out we will never
again return to our home our home has
been closed
as rita told me almost 40 years later
the man at the steamship company told
her your island has been sold you will
never go there again
when rita's husband julienne banku
heard his wife's news he collapsed
backwards his arms splayed wide
unable to utter a word
prevented from returning home rita
julienne and their five children found
themselves in a foreign country
separated from their home their land
their animals their possessions
their jobs their community and the
graves of their ancestors
the bankus had been as chagosians came
to say de racine
deracinated uprooted
torn from their natal lands
his sickness started to take hold of him
rita explained
he didn't understand a thing she said
soon julian suffered a stroke his body
growing rigid and increasingly paralyzed
before the year was out rita would spend
several weeks in a psychiatric hospital
receiving treatment
five years after suffering his stroke
julian bancu died
rita said the cause of death was
sagra
profound sorrow
there wasn't sickness like strokes or
sagra in chagos rita explained there
wasn't that sickness nor diabetes nor
any such illness
what drugs she asked rhetorically
this is what my husband remembered and
pictured in his mind
me too
i remember these things that i've said
about us david
my heart grows heavy when i say these
things
understand
after julian's death the bank's son alex
lost his job as a dock worker
he later died at 38 addicted to drugs
and alcohol
another son eddie died at 36 of a heroin
overdose
another son renault died suddenly at age
11 after suffering from flu-like
symptoms after selling water and begging
for money at a local cemetery near their
home
my life has been buried rita told me
from her torn brown vinyl couch in her
small sitting room in mauritius
what do i think about it she continued
it's as if i was pulled from my paradise
to put me in hell
everything here you need to buy
i don't have the means to buy them
my children go without eating
how am i supposed to bear this life
in the book i explore more what rita
described about her husband's death that
he died of sagra of profound sorrow
as i found that many chagosians
described many of their
community members having died of of sad
grave sorrow of sadness of a broken
heart
i wanted to understand this better
as something of a medical anthropologist
wanted to understand could could people
die of a broken heart of sadness
here's how rita described segre
segre that's to say it's a graph for his
country
where he came from he didn't experience
abject poverty like he was experiencing
here
he was seeing it in his eyes chagos
his children were going without were
going without food
they didn't have anything rita said of
julian's death
and so he got so so many worries
do you understand
that's segre
many people have died like that you know
david
died from i started to ask wanting to
understand more about how people could
die from segre
said grant yes
when one has said gran in your heart it
eats at you
no doctor no one will be able to heal
you
if you have a sagra if you even
you can't get it out
that's to say david i owe
what can you do
there's so many people that can't bear
it
um i uttered trying to take in what she
was saying yes do you understand then it
goes it goes until at the end
you don't want to eat you don't want
anything nothing you don't want it
there's nothing you do
there's nothing that you have that's
good
you've withdrawn from the world
completely and entered into a state of
segre
have you experienced that grant i asked
yes
segre
yes rita replied slowly
it's very hard i said
do you understand you have said grant
when in your country you haven't
experienced things like this
here you're finding food in the trash
can
and in fact jagocians aren't at all
alone in describing people as having
died of of segre of sorrow of sadness of
heartbreak um there's medical evidence
that that other displaced peoples that
people
the elderly were forced into nursing
homes against their will
can have acute cardiac
arrests and heart attacks
in what are otherwise healthy cardiac
systems
and just before i completed the book my
grandmother reminded me that her mother
my great great my great grandmother
died of a broken heart
my great-grandmother sent my grandmother
from nazi germany just before world war
ii
um to the united states as a 17 year old
and my great-grandmother and my
great-grandfather sent my mother's my
grandmother's brother
to what they presume would be the safety
of amsterdam they didn't want to burden
my grandmother as a 17 year old with
having to to take her 13 year old
brother along to the states so they sent
him to
live with family in amsterdam where he
was ultimately
sent to auschwitz and murdered
and my grandmother explained to me how
after learning of his fate my great
grandmother never talked about her son
again
and in 1947 suffered a major heart
attack
and then spent the next 10 years living
as an invalid much like julian bancou
actually
largely paralyzed and living under my
grandmother's care
when she finally died her doctor said
she had died of a broken heart
my grandmother explained the guilt she
carried with her ultimately just broke
her heart my grandmother said
can someone die of a broken heart my
grandmother asked
yes it's possible
if you're anything like me it may be
difficult to fully grasp the pain of
having been deracinae
having been uprooted
like me you probably live a
fairly transient life
much far more transient than the the
life the jagosians once lived
like me you may be someone who expects
to move several times in a lifetime
following
and moving place to place in search of
employment opportunities education
following family members even romance
still we can and must try to imagine
what being forcibly uprooted and torn
from chagos felt like for the chagosians
who had been living there for
generations some lev never leaving their
islands
i asked rita again what it felt like
that day when she heard she would never
again return to chagos
enormous anguish enormous problems for
me replied rita
how can i explain it
you know there was a child that i
breastfed
she grew all the way up to 17 months
and despite it all she died
it left me with enormous grief
the same grief the same as when i lost a
let when i lost eddie
the same suffering david
the same suffering i repeated the same
suffering and how can i say it
when i have that suffering there's a
time when i
there's a time when i remember there's a
time when i forget
but that moment i turn it over i turn it
over in my mind
because i've had so many problems david
if my children and grandchildren were
born there
it would be something different
they would have had a different house
they would have had a different
everything
the same as i had
in fact the the jagosians are of course
you know sadly not at all alone in what
they've experienced in many in many ways
um among them i've been able to document
at least 17
cases in which
the u.s military has displaced local
populations during the construction of
u.s military facilities some are fairly
well known to others the case of vieques
puerto rico and the bikini islands where
we conducted nuclear testing in the
beginning in the 1940s
others are less well-known like the
people of thule greenland who
experienced a similar fate to the
chigosians
and people in okinawa who were displaced
over a period of about 10 years to of
all places bolivia
where
they found none of what was promised to
them there
other cases in in hawaii
alaska
and guam to name just a few of them
and i i think it's
critical to point out that those 17
cases follow
more than a century during which the
united states
forcibly displaced and expropriated the
lands of native american peoples on this
continent
gary sick one of the u.s government
officials who i interviewed for the book
described it
this way
the fact is that nobody cared very much
about these populations
said former defense department official
gary sick who testified before congress
about the removals in 1975 on the only
day that congress has ever taken up the
issue
it was more of a 19th century decision
thought process
than a 20th or 21st century thought
process
and i think that was the bind they got
caught in
that this was sort of colonial thinking
after the fact about what they could do
and us officials six said we're pleased
to let the british do their dirty work
for them
we'll just say quickly and part of the
book takes up these issues in more
detail um
that diego garcia and the story of the
chagosians also points
to
and helps us to understand ways in which
the united states has become an empire
and has been an empire since its
independence but it ways in which it has
become a new kind of empire in the 20th
century an empire of bases as many put
it um diego garcia is one of 1 000 at
least a thousand u.s military bases that
we have outside the 50 states in
washington dc
um
little known again little known to to
people in this country
we have
hundreds of bases in gua in excuse me in
germany japan
south korea bases of course in iraq and
afghanistan and in far-flung places
like
kuwait gutter bahrain colombia honduras
and of course guantanamo bay
um iceland romania bulgaria
truly a global network of of military
bases
and diego garcia helps show how these
bases unlike the the european colonial
empires which depended on the control of
large swathes of territory colonies um
to exert their dominance and control the
united states has become this empire
basis where the control of very discreet
pieces of territory have allowed us to
exert our power and control other over
other nations working in tandem with
economic and political forms of power
largely since world war ii when we began
accumulating this huge collection of
bases
and diego garcia in particular
shows how
bases and the base of diego garcia
especially
have been especially critical to our
control over the middle east and its oil
and natural gas supplies and increasing
over over central asia
um
and i
part i end the book in asking us to
think about the ways in which our lives
are connected to the lives of the
chicosians how the the lives we depend
on which are so dependent on cheap gas
and an economy um that runs on cheap oil
um
are connected to um the suffering that
the chagosians have experienced and how
our everyday lives are connected to the
lives they're living today
um
in addition to the the ways in which
diego garcia
helps us see um
that there's been a single strategic
vision since at least world war ii in
which the united states has attempted to
control and dominate
the middle east and persian gulf and its
its oil and natural gas supplies
and in which diego garcia has been come
to play a central role
just say one more thing about that and
then i'll turn to i'll conclude by
talking about the tragosian struggle to
return
in part i i end by by thinking about
what you know what what can we learn um
from this story about u.s foreign policy
and the ways in which the united states
is engaged with the rest of the world
as we consider the empire that the
united states has become
we must face the damage that the nation
has inflicted on people like the
jugosians families like the bankus and
so many others
we cannot allow the harmful effects of
u.s empire too often ignored or given
short shrift by empire's proponents and
others
to continue
we cannot continue to allow claims of
national interest
to justify the destruction of the lives
of others
the story of diego garcia is in many
ways a story of just that
how we have allowed empire and
militarism to trump human lives
but in the face of what they've
experienced it's important to to point
out that the jugosians have been far
from from silent um from the beginning
of their expulsion
in their first years in exile they sent
a petition to the governments of britain
and and the united states
that read in part
we the inhabitants of chagos islands
diego garcia perospanos solomon have
been uprooted from these islands our
ancestors were slaves on those islands
but we know that we are the heirs of
those islands
although we were poor there we were not
dying of hunger we were living free
and they've continued to struggle
through protests hunger strikes
petitions um through the years beginning
in 1997
and that's what led their finally
getting some compensation i should point
out that it wasn't just that the british
government and the mauritian government
finally decided to give them some money
it took literally women
and the movement was almost entirely led
by women
going on hunger strike and leading
major protests in the mauritian capital
to to get that compensation but
beginning in 1997 um the uh the
chagosians began suing the u.s and
british governments for the right to
return
again that's how i came to the case
in the united states unfortunately their
cases was dismissed in 2004
it's very difficult for non-us citizens
to
sue successfully the u.s government and
the case was dismissed
as being a matter of military and
foreign policy that is left to
the executive branch largely and a realm
in which the judiciary is supposedly
not to have much leeway
and i think we could talk about this
later i think the case raises some
interesting questions about
the united states is upholding human
rights guarantees and the ability of of
people to to
hold the united states responsible for
damaging their lives and in many ways so
i think they're broad implications there
in the uk the chicanes have been much
more successful having won three major
lawsuits in 2000
2006 and 2007 in which
british courts the high court in london
has ruled their expulsion unlawful under
british law calling the expulsion
repugnant and an abuse of power
unfortunately last october the highest
court in the uk the house of lords
overturned those lower court rulings
by a three to two verdict ruling
that
the military and financial
considerations of the british government
could trump the jugosian's right of
abode and their right to return
which i think again essentially that the
ruling upheld colonial law the the right
of the british executive in the name of
the queen to make laws for
colonized people the chagosians part of
the british indian ocean territory um
they are now um appealing that ruling to
the european court of human rights where
they expect to have a um and hope to
have a better a better hearing
um and just last um
about six weeks ago in march
the european union passed a resolution
calling for the eu
to support the chigosians uh right to
return and and they're resettling their
their islands and in fact the jegos have
a an entire resettlement plan that i
could describe later
so what you see is growing international
momentum in support of the chagosians
right of return and their efforts to
return
in the uk and elsewhere in europe
in africa and increasingly here in the
u.s
um the chicago students are hoping to
begin
lobbying the obama administration and
hoping that the obama administration
will be
um
we'll have a again a more sympathetic
year and begin to accept the
responsibility
of the us government that successive
administrations have consistently denied
and in fact that's you know
my hope for the book is that it it will
raise awareness in this country about a
story that very few people know about
and play some role in bringing justice
to the chagosians
and in addition to you know taking a
look at the book and usually i'd be shy
about encouraging people to buy the book
but i'm i'm giving all the the proceeds
all the royalties from the book to the
chagosians so if you get a copy it is a
contribution to that you go seeing so um
but more importantly or as importantly
um tell others about the tragosians and
their their struggle um i've got a sign
up sheet for
a support group that's getting started
um some more information about other
resources
and um
i only have a few copies left because
people in the barrier are so great and
have
filled so many out
but we're sending um postcards to oprah
um to ask her to put the chagosians on
tv um to put people like rita bancou and
her son olivier um on tv um to tell
their story and you know who better to
tell their story um
so
with that i just want to conclude
actually with the words of rita bancu's
son olivier bancu who is the president
of the chagos refugees group the group
leading the lawsuits and and most of
their struggle
we are the descendants of slaves our
skin is black we don't have blue eyes
whether we are black whether we are
white whether we are yellow we all must
have the same treatment
that is the treatment that the chigosian
community is asking for
that is the treatment we want
sorry that is the treatment that
suggestion community is asking for at
least give us our chance to live
give us our chance to live like every
other human being
stop all the injustices that have been
committed against us
so thanks and why don't i take some
questions now
glory i'm just wondering now that it's
been a couple generations have probably
been born since since the people
actually lived there
were sent to mauritius
is there danger that
that people will forget that a lot of
the people who really could or should be
leading the charge now never actually
been to diego garcia
yeah um that that is a danger um and i
should mention that the the size of the
population now is over 5 000 with those
who've been born
in exile
um and the members of the second and
third generations born in exile have
different relationships with with chagos
having never visited there some very
much want to move back some don't know
it's sort of an abstract question do you
want to move back to a place you've
never lived in and you've only heard
about their stories some feel deeply
robbed that they
didn't have a chance to grow up in the
islands um but in fact i think the
british government it's pretty clear
understands that dynamic and and has
been trying to drag out the process in
the hopes that more and more of the
generation born in chagos um will die
and and that the momentum for the
movement will die out with them
um there there are many in the second
and third generations who are were a
major part of the struggle so
um
things look hopeful for their continuing
it but hopefully the there's still about
six seven hundred of the generation born
in chagos so
their hope and my hope is that they will
get to return far before that generation
leaves us
the name of the island sounds so unlike
the other names is there a story of
conquest behind that um
no just a story of of portuguese
explorers
being the first to name it in the
european world
indian or chinese or arab explorers
likely
named it before although we don't
know what they named it
maybe eddie and then
is there a historical precedent are
there examples where generations later
uh people have been successful in
being allowed to return uh
whether it's allowed whatever the verb
is
something like this anywhere in the
world
um
i can i can think of a few um
uh well
in the strongest parallel would be the
people of bikini
um who've been allowed to go back
although that was a complicated return
where they returned and then found that
their islands were still irradiated and
had to leave and then come back
um
you know they're um
well the people of vieques have have
gotten back their island in complicated
ways and they don't they still don't
have total control um
uh the people of collaborate next to
vieques also there was a plan to
to
displace all of them as well they were
lucky enough to
through struggle um make sure that that
didn't happen i mean you can also think
about israel as an example of
people returning many many many
generations
removed and i'm sure they're better
examples that aren't coming my mind
others might
might think of them
i was curious
specifically what the remedy
is being said what is the resettlement
plan
what's the proposal
um with the help of some consultants
they've put together a a resettlement
plan
um that would focus on rebuilding their
societies around mostly around high-end
tourism um these are gorgeous tropical
islands very isolated um and similar
islands in the seychelles are are very
much sought after by mostly by european
tourists
so the idea would be to build a
an economy based around high-end tourism
and then some small handicrafts um some
coconut
processing
as before
on small levels at the beginning and
then to build it up slowly over
time the initial tourism would be um
constructed on the outer islands the
islands like where rita bancou came from
parasponis which are over a hundred
miles away um and in fact or
the jagosians can't go back but if you
have a yacht i don't know if anyone here
has the yacht but um if you have a yacht
um you can go visit the outer islands
you can't go to diego garcia but british
and us officials let yachties as they're
called
stop at the islands live there for weeks
months at a time having barbecues on the
on the beaches and um but on occasions
when chigosians have come mostly on
fishing boats um they've been sent on
their way um
by british officials
um so and then but i should mention the
other part that the trigon's many of
them not all of them many of them want
the right to work on the base where
they've been prevented from working
there are
non-us non-british
civilian contractors working on the base
um mauritians sri lankans filipinos and
others
and trigoceans want
to have that right too
one to have a job and two to be back on
their
their home islands
well what's what's the political vision
for you know is it sort of as an
independent state or part of mauritius
because it was or
that's a complicated and uh and very uh
touchy question in mauritius itself um
because mauritius actually claims diego
garcia and the rest of the archipelago
saying that they were improperly taken
from them as they were the
decolonization process under the
decolonization process established by
the u.n colonies were not supposed to be
divided up when they were getting their
independence which is in fact what what
britain did
um so mauritius claims the island so its
future sovereignty is a very um touchy
political question
and the tragosians mostly want say that
most important to them is getting back
whoever controls it that's another
question
but if you talk to you know some will
say we want to stay british some will
say we want to want it to be mauritian
some will say you know down the road
we'd like to have our own sovereignty
but
first and foremost we want to have the
right to return
i just had a question about what was it
called sun sun grin
segre
from the french the sugar
so um
was this an illness i mean as you
describe it it seemed like the ones you
described were coming it was arising
after the after the
forced expulsion
um was this an illness with a history
uh
back to diego garcia did you get a sense
of that and and were there healers who
you know
were
would deal with that
no um definitely not and people would
explain this was something we didn't
have
in
in diego garcia and the other islands
that it was something that emerged in
exile um that it's very much a disease
of the combination of living in abject
poverty and and the the sadness of being
separated from one's homeland
um
and just to give you the broader sort of
health context um jagossian's health was
actually quite good in in chagos
it was better than that in mauritius
despite not having quite as good medical
treatment facilities
so in this larger context of ill health
um you see people dying of of sag of a
broken heart
just quickly on um
who who was introducing the resolution
in the european he said it was european
parliament um
there were two they've filed a lawsuit
in the european court of human rights um
which the british government has to
respond to
early in june
and then the eu the european union
passed a resolution
calling on the eu to assist in the the
return of the trigon
came from like who what country or
how it got introduced i believe um by um
uk parliamentarians in the in the
european parliament um there's now a
group of um over 40 members of
parliament both
uk members of parliament and eu
parliamentarians
and lords who've created an all-party
group um in britain to support the
chagosians and their their right to
return and put pressure on the
the government
and you said you're trying to you know
at least make some attempt to get
something going here a support group of
some sort
there's a support group that's going to
get started and the chagosians hope um
in september to come actually olivier
bancu to come and and to dc and and
begin lobbying the obama administration
and they have some with help with some
of their lawyers here in the u.s and and
others they have some some support for
that for that
um but can use all the help they can get
um
you know there are very small people
five thousand a little more than five
thousand
trying to
move you know
the two major powers of the worlds um
and
it's an upheld battle but as the case
you know
for years they had two members of
parliament who said you know
who took up their cause and suddenly
they have now they have more than 40
just in the past couple years so there's
a lot of momentum building but there's a
long way to go generally and especially
a long way to go here you know to begin
to get people to take notice and and
take up their cause and that that's what
it's going to take that
for people to begin advocating for them
here
yeah actually
nancy pelosi once in 2000 lobbying on
the african growth and opportunity
how the lawyers that
came to you got involved themselves to
begin with yeah oh how they got involved
themselves yes and and also if you want
to talk about how you got involved um i
essentially was just very lucky because
um
through a series of connections at
our graduate school um but the lawyers
got involved also through a nice series
of connections where the chagosians
lawyer and mauritius had gone to school
in france
and um and had studied under michael
tiger who's a fairly well known lawyer
here who has voted in california the
third the third
best lawyer in the 20th century after
clarence darrow and thurgood marshall
he's represented angela davis and
a number of other high profile
folks
and so through that connection in france
he approached when they wanted to launch
a u.s suit he approached him and another
interesting tidbit about that is that um
that the the suits have been here in the
u.s were financed by big tobacco
essentially um
tiger had represented some lawyers in
tobacco suits in texas and won a sizable
judgment and took all that money
to fund human rights impact litigation
lawsuits including this one and i've
never been employed by them or paid by
them but some of my research expenses
were essentially paid by big tobacco
so
sort of nice
thank you smokers everywhere
um
unless there are any other burning
questions maybe we can continue the
discussion
informally but i really thank you all
for listening thank you for your support
and being here
for me it means a tremendous amount and
yeah just overjoyed so thank you
[Applause]
david vine is an anthropology professor
at american university in washington d.c
for more information visit david
vine.net